Hypnotize
[inaudible] your average tourist cabbage off instinct
Detroit players.
Since those girls never lose,
never choose to do something to us,
talk to us girls,
job hopper and functions like stars and just stick the crash there.
I squeeze three at your cherry
easily recently,
Nigga starting again
saying nothing is there.
I just speak my piece to keep my piss Cubans with the Jesus keys.
My keys test,
test,
test.
Is that something that someone did actually with Siri?
It's hacks.
This is somebody hacked her iPhone.
You can tell when he opens it and closest is a,
it has a weird,
uh,
I look to it.
So I think somebody just,
you know,
oh,
they do that.
They do that.
They root I iPhones as well.
Oh yeah.
I didn't know that people were hacking into I of course,
I think there's like websites you can just go to and it's just,
uh,
were you,
what Hell looks hacked about that?
That looks like just the iPhone.
Uh,
when we say that.
Okay.
Uh,
I guess,
no,
it looks like I thought the icons on the two top or something,
but that looks like soundcloud.
So yeah,
that looks like a normal iPhone.
Well,
I think that's the only way you could possibly do it.
I think that has to be a Haq di phone or the whole thing is fake because of the
whole thing is much more likely fake because there's one thing I noticed at the
very end of this video,
which you can find on Vimeo,
uh,
he,
it says something different than she says on the writing here.
So maybe this writing part was just,
you know,
an I,
final cut pro or something.
Well,
it's a Siri,
Siri,
can't you see too,
I mean,
someone typed that in and what is that?
Oh,
yeah,
yeah.
It's definitely not,
it's definitely not Siri.
They definitely did it either fake the video or they,
they routed their iPhone,
but I think it's probably more fake.
That's like a big thing with the android people,
man,
android,
that's the one thing that they love about it.
The fact that you can do that.
Yeah.
Do to get into Andrew,
they're like,
dudes were like really into fucking Unix and shit.
Right.
You know,
like rooting things.
I'm a,
I'm a Linux contributor dude.
We forgot to record the video blog again.
Yeah.
We keep forgetting.
Sorry folks.
So he had to go though.
You really did that go.
He he did had to go to,
did have to leave.
That was a fascinating guy though,
wasn't it?
Yeah.
That was really interesting and it definitely,
it was a shit that I've already thought about before,
you know?
And it's kind of interesting to hear it from somebody that has some credit.
Yeah.
I think,
you know,
as you get older in life and you have a certain amount of experiences and you
sort of learn
okay
the way the world's been working for you,
you know,
you start thinking,
I,
if it works like this,
I wonder if this is really what's going on.
And that's basically like every I wonder that I ever had and he just comes out
and says,
yes it does.
Yes.
Your,
your mind,
your consciousness controls everything.
Your environment controls how the genes are made.
Like,
what the fuck,
by the way,
dude,
fear factor last night.
It was so great to see it.
Like I forgot how much I missed it.
I,
yeah,
I've,
I've watched every single episode,
even till the very end,
I watched it.
And it wasn't because of you or anything,
I just,
that was a show that I thought was always fun to Crane Jack and just,
you know,
you,
you had more emotion of just sitting there with a blank look staring at a TV.
You're actually like,
like,
I'm just like,
Ooh.
You know,
like if it freaks you out a little bit better than most shows.
So last night it was also awesome seeing it,
taking it to the next level.
It's what's the HD I thought was so awesome that you could actually see like the
bugs,
intestines and stuff like that,
you know,
in more detail and the explosions.
I'm pretty sure sound editing on that show's awesome.
Bad ass dude.
I watched it was very surreal watching it.
Very surreal.
Yeah.
And you know,
it's just,
it's a strange,
the whole thing was strange.
It was something strange to live it and strange to do it again.
It's strange to see it on TV again.
I fucking never thought I would be doing that shogun.
I never thought how could it happen?
This is a I just a chapter in my life and I've moved past that now and then to
do it again.
But I,
I enjoyed it man.
I really did.
I thought it was fun.
I thought it was a fun fucking show.
Was that,
was that mom and uh,
uh,
the sun thing real.
That's all real disturbing.
Oh yeah.
Well,
you know what the casting my boy rich really knows how to fucking bring these
people in.
They know how to pick a man at this point in time too.
There's so many people that want to do any sort of a reality show that you could
find some real characters and you can find some that,
that one character that the guy that,
uh,
that was like a self motivator guy with the hot blonde.
She left,
she didn't know how to swim and he just left her drowning like in the middle of
the water.
That was felt bad for that girl.
You know,
I felt bad that she didn't know how to swim and she'd tried to do that.
she like,
she wanted to win and she thought maybe once you got in there she should figure
out how to do it,
but she didn't know how to swim.
That was disturbing at a rescuer.
It's weird.
You guys didn't see it idea.
I think they had a plan.
I think the plan was he said,
I know you don't know how to swim,
but I'll carry you.
Right.
I don't think you realize how hard that is to do.
It's really hard to do and you swim slow as fuck when you're doing that.
Like you can't just swim when you're carrying someone's body.
It takes a long time.
It takes like more than half,
more than twice the time to,
you know,
she was pulling him down and he was panicking so he left her out there.
It's they thinking not,
not being able to swim,
that you should not be a grown adult,
that that should be like something that they have to teach you in like third
grade and you have to pass a test.
She apparently she didn't grow up in the best neighborhood.
You know,
she wasn't happy about it.
Obviously grew up in Vegas.
Right?
That hot chick.
I Dunno.
They're changing.
She grew up,
she grew up in that Mandalay bay.
She's so high.
She was so hot that check.
She was very pretty.
I wonder if she was like his friend and they came on like as a,
uh,
like he hired her.
Yeah.
That's,
that seems like it makes more sense.
Yeah,
it's very possible.
And then she just agreed to get it.
I mean,
why not?
Why not just say,
you know,
say it's my boyfriend and I would do that.
You want to get on couples here fact together we do.
We have to be coupled.
Yeah.
We'll just pretend.
Okay.
That's why he left her in the water.
That makes that 100% sense.
Right?
Well,
never.
You'd never leave your girl in the water if you thought you were drowning.
You might,
if you thought someone would rescue her,
if you separated,
you might separate,
but you would say something.
Save her.
You would say saver.
You know,
that's what I would say.
I would say,
you know,
if I knew that I couldn't rescuer if like if she like first of all,
if someone does not swim at all and they're flailing around,
they can drag you under.
Right?
You have to get them to relax.
So you have to be fucking good at that.
That's not an easy thing to do.
Like when just start kissing them.
Right.
And then they get in a couple of fear,
embrace stuck her finger and put it right in the pooper.
Calm him down.
Like when you've got a whole good hold over their pooper and especially the
thumb,
you press the thumb on the coccsyx instead of,
I just want to say toxic six.
And it was also so weird seeing it cause it was all ex boyfriend
ex-girlfriend's,
which I thought it was a great idea for casting wise.
But it was weird seeing that like that one guy that where I,
there was a guy in this girl that was like fake boobs or I think she had fake
boobs but like kind of a weird body,
you know,
like hot,
older body.
And he,
she,
he just like fucking with her.
Like she controlled the whole relationship.
It was weird seeing like why people broke up probably because he,
she was like,
like,
you know,
he was,
yes ma'am.
Yes ma'am.
I don't know if you remember that,
that,
that guy that,
uh,
like he pretty much took orders from her the whole time during fear factor.
Yes.
Yeah,
totally.
Yeah.
So you can kind of see why like the relationships like ended like it was so
interesting.
I like it.
It's why they chose those people,
you know,
they chose them because they knew there would be fascinating to watch.
You know,
it's,
it's weird how my,
how bad some people's relationships are.
It's weird,
you know?
But there was some people that were fun,
like fun relationships,
like the one couple,
they were exes,
but uh,
now they're just friends.
The twilight kid.
Here's the deal.
Pretty friendly to team twilight.
That was so funny,
hilarious and hard writer or easy rider,
but they were very nice people.
They're super cool.
Yeah,
she was gorgeous.
she's really pretty.
And he was a good looking guy and they were,
they were actually friends.
I mean it was legit is they used to date and they didn't work out and they both
have different girlfriends now or boyfriends and their friends.
It was still the healthiest fucking group by far out of any of them.
The other ones like so fucking easy riders.
Those guys were fighting like cats and dogs.
And then the other guy you felt sorry for that one dude,
I felt controlled by his wife,
his ex.
It was sad,
you know,
and she would say shit and you're just like,
oh,
hoard dude.
He has to just sit there and eat that.
You know,
I couldn't do that with my exes.
I not most of them.
I could sue is you don't want to be in that position.
Everyone knows that.
You don't want to be in that disadvantageous position where you are.
You are giving into them all
the time.
Right.
You know,
you don't want to be there,
man.
You don't want to be there where they're yelling at you.
You don't want to be there that,
that,
that position sucks.
Yeah.
And that one guy even was like,
you know,
like he dropped a cow heart,
I think it was,
he dropped the cow heart and uh,
and you could tell that she was blaming him for losing it and then like somebody
else dropped it and he goes,
yeah,
see,
look,
it was hard to see.
It was hard to see,
you know,
like he,
it was,
it was so sad to see that.
Yeah.
It's hard.
It's hard dealing with people like that.
Not dealing with them.
I mean,
but you know,
being around them and going,
hey,
you guys are just fucking up.
He took his life.
You don't need to get the fuck away from her dude.
I know you feel like some,
I know that you've got this connection with her,
right?
You know,
you got to see her get your kids from her.
But other than that stay away because this woman is chopping you down.
Yeah.
You know what to do.
Can't get a chicken anymore.
When a girl is no longer impressed with the guy when the fucking magic is over
and she is not attracted to the guy at all,
that is the worst time you can be around that girl cause she will have you
feeling like you are worthless and that will in turn,
it's not going to motivate you.
It's going to make you feel like shit and it's gonna probably ruin all these
other aspects of your life too.
So if you want a regular relationship with someone who treats you like shit and
is not whatsoever attracted to,
that's devastating for you as a person.
And so like when we were around this poor guy,
we have to see this like,
oh you can't blame her.
She knew you like who you like,
man,
but you got to,
you know,
for him,
he's got to get the fuck away,
man run.
This is your reality you're creating as Bruce Lipton would tell us,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
Speaking of which,
man,
I have to apologize to uh,
to Todd bridges.
Man,
I fucked up and a,
I did this interview and um,
they,
uh,
you know,
they always ask you what was it like the old fear factor.
You do a hundred interviews and after awhile he just,
you just run out of shit to talk about and you'll,
you'll talk about anything.
And one of the things that came up,
we were talking about c listers that were on the show and I'm gonna just read it
so there's no mistake whatsoever.
And what I said the question was,
the guy says,
I remember it was more c listers and blast from the past,
like Todd bridges.
And I said,
yeah,
he was a really weird one.
He's an angry dude.
I think he murdered somebody.
Don't go,
did he get away with manslaughter?
I'm serious.
You shouldn't print that.
Uh,
because I think it says you shouldn't print it.
Said you should print that.
But that's not what I said.
I said,
you shouldn't print that because I think he got in some sort of a fight in a
crack house and wound up killing someone.
Hold on,
let me fact check right now.
They actually put the whole thing and me saying,
why bother?
Let me fact check right now.
And then I say,
yeah.
Todd bridges attempted murder and attempted voluntary manslaughter charges.
He shot somebody five gunshots and a knife wound.
The jury acquitted him though.
That was 1989.
He was 23 years old.
Uh,
then I said,
but yeah,
I didn't enjoy being with him.
He was a weird,
angry guy.
Blamed his,
uh,
losing on the producers like they wanted to get rid of him.
Uh,
there's some people who just think that the world is out to get them.
And he felt like that in a big way.
It was interesting from a psychological standpoint.
This is one of the reason why,
so this,
he got upset at me when he got eliminated from the show and wouldn't believe
that he was actually eliminated.
He believed that they wanted him to get eliminated.
I went to shake his hand and he wouldn't even shake my hand.
He just like put his hands back and walked away.
I was like,
this is so fucking childish that thought about,
I'm like this poor guy,
man,
you know,
he grows up in the,
in the limelight on a fucking big show.
Like different strokes,
like try developing on television like that.
We've talked about that so many times,
like how insane that must be tried developing on television.
So all I did was comment on him,
like,
you know,
like he wasn't a person common Emily,
like I wasn't,
I wasn't concerned with his feelings that he would listen to it.
And despite the fact that,
you know,
he wasn't some sort of a situation to crack house.
You know,
this was a long time ago and you know,
I don't know him and I just said it and I shouldn't have said it.
It's really,
you know,
even whether it's true or not is not the point.
The point is there's no reason for me to say it.
And he's friends with my friend Dave and my friend Dave and him talked and he
said he's been sober for 19 years and this upset Him and I'm thought about it.
I'm like,
who the fuck am I to just randomly bring up some shit about some dudes passed
that's going to make him feel bad.
You know,
it's,
it was not,
it was,
there was no reason why I should have done it.
I did it.
Uh,
I was,
it was lazy thinking on my part.
I should have never done it and I should have,
you know,
looked at his life as like one picture.
I don't know that dude.
And apparently he's been sober for like 19 years and he does a lot of good
things.
It does interventions and shit.
So I opened up my mouth when I shouldn't have and a,
I apologize.
So Todd bridges,
if you're out there,
please accept my apology.
I'm sorry,
I shouldn't have said that.
It wasn't he.
He's right.
I totally agree.
I could have totally avoided saying anything about his past or anything about
him as a person.
I get bored sometimes men,
and this is no excuse,
but it's true.
You know,
he'd do a hundred interviews about fear factor and stuff like that.
You can get psychologically lazy,
you know,
he gets sloppy with what you say and you as you can see everything I said there
including don't print that which actually says or instead of shouldn't print
that.
It actually says should print that.
But I most certainly said shouldn't print that because I went into some sort of
a,
I went to fact check that.
So because of that they put every single word I said.
So you've got to,
you get a chance to see my whole thought process on it.
So I don't know what the fuck happened to him.
Obviously I wasn't there and the guy got acquitted.
Good.
That's beautiful.
You know,
um,
I don't,
I don't hold any ill will towards him and I feel bad that I brought it up and I
shouldn't have.
So I apologize.
You know that,
that,
that the NT and they shouldn't,
it shouldn't is going to be the new tower seven for you
because we're going this way.
I said well I'm a mumble and fuck.
You know you talked to me over the phone,
especially with these goofy headsets that I insist on wearing,
you know,
visiting those things I have,
I walk around my house so I like it cause I can talk on the phone and do shit at
the same time.
Crew style.
But Tom Cruise 1984 yeah.
Actually I've got a cord and the cord goes directly into the cordless phone but
it's the best way to do it because the phone's cordless.
Deponent's Dixon my back pocket.
It's got a little clip and I can walk around the house.
I play pool when I'm on the phone sometimes.
Yeah.
But that's why radio shack is still in business because of people like you
buying those created from radio shack.
You got to get them from hello,
direct direct fat.
Hello.
Direct is the best company in the world for business phones.
Hello?
Yeah.
They make a big conference phones and they make a really good headsets that you
listen to a cordless phone on where it's like real high end.
It sounds really good,
really strong,
but he's expensive equipment,
but it's expensive because it's really high end stuff.
It's really worth it.
But you know,
you get any fucking headset,
man.
I got a Sony one that was like 30 bucks.
It's pretty good.
It's not bad at all.
You know?
You sure?
Hella direct does not like a home shopping network.
Bluetooth accessories?
I don't think so.
I think they make cell phone.
I mean,
I think they make a phone headsets.
The John Heffron attorney
payments game.
My in denial.
I think that's what that John [inaudible] has never tried to rip us off.
I just want to be clear about that.
He's a great guy and he would never do anything dishonest,
but John Hafod occasionally has these fucking plans.
We're like,
dude,
all I have to do is a,
I start this one business and Uganda,
you know,
I give them the keys and they have money that comes to me for the rest of my
life.
Dude,
I'm sad like he's got like this sort of like crazy lottery winner,
scam mentality sort of a thing.
As far as like him wanting to like find some one product that really takes off
like what is it like an Anthony Robbins thing?
Cause I know he's into that shit.
I don't know.
I don't even know who that is.
That is,
you know Anthony Robin says I googled that was it for me.
I don't know if I answered her need that information.
I just use Google.
I might know who you never heard of.
Tony Robbins.
You know who Tony Robbins is?
The motivational speaker guy.
He's fucking gigantic is huge.
No.
Is he like a bublé because I just found out about bublé and now he's haunting
play some bublé guy that sings a lot and and,
and now it like somebody told me,
do you know who Mike Williams?
And then now how do I go?
I tried to buy a bottle of wine last night and was like,
oh,
you just want a free bublé album.
I don't know who this bublé guy guys,
but it's just a new character,
a new dude.
I,
it seems like it's not.
I got shamed down because I don't know who bublé is.
Do you have some music?
No.
You can't even play,
I can't play movie.
We don't want to get sued by the latest and greatest bublé but he's haunting me
down the way.
It's the holiday season or something.
I have no idea what you're talking about.
I never even heard of this.
Well now you will find,
you'll get boob blade nonstop.
You will find bublé everywhere.
I don't think I will.
Yeah,
you will.
I'm,
I'm guessing in your reality with the poop like,
Hey,
can you can't win over my reality.
I control my own reality.
You can't get in.
Oh yeah,
it's an impenetrable bubble,
sir.
You'll find out who to blame me.
You'll be driving some links.
They won't even enter my mind.
I'll look at it.
I'll click on the link.
I'll go,
oh,
it's Brian.
I'm sorry.
You just got me to do you think so?
The blade all over your face.
You think so dude,
I all I know is I want to be on the tonight show on Friday with Ron fucking Paul
musical guests.
Bublé w you are my God.
But you imagine if it was,
I would just pull my pants down.
Shit over.
Blessed diary over Jay's desk.
I've been on the Kale shakes a lot lately,
man.
My,
my poop is fantastic.
I love that dude.
It can bublé is the new Kale [inaudible] is the new Kale.
Yeah.
It's because I,
you came with me.
I was going to be to lose olive garden.
I'm going to throw a fucking bottle of water.
I do.
I went to the olive garden the other day and it wasn't that good.
What happened?
Um,
I tried all their new stuff and it was like,
oh,
they're trying to get crafty.
No,
no,
it's not even that.
It's like I've found that if I eat late at night,
so like I always go like at nine o'clock when it closes at 10 and you could tell
the kitchen starts to break down at a certain moment.
I most restaurants like kitchen,
it's like,
all right,
we can start to break down.
Meaning you could stop making new soup,
you can start putting everything away,
you know,
because there's only a few people left,
to order food.
And I feel like lately,
every time I go to a restaurant at that time period,
it's sucks.
And like the,
the Ravioli I had was like overcooked.
The,
they have like,
uh,
they have lasagna that's deep fried now or something like that.
It's so awesome.
But that was like,
it felt like it was sitting in the Fryer for 20 minutes.
So they probably,
you know,
pre cooked it or something like that.
But don't go to a restaurant after nine o'clock is what I'm saying.
Yo,
you'll have not as good as food as tired.
Well,
it's just because they,
they start closing down in the kitchen because it's about to close and people
retired.
My fault.
Don't go to the olive garden after nine o'clock to 6:00 PM sort of a meal.
I'm on the road lunch without any restaurant.
Just what I'm saying?
No,
not just all of garden.
Any restaurant.
Godsey
dinner with Anthony Bourdain.
Oh really?
Yeah,
in Toronto.
Where'd you go?
Some restaurant,
some nice place.
It was pretty cool.
We got there when it was about to close and,
uh,
they had a bar and we sat in the bar area and they said,
you know,
the regular menus close,
but we've got this menu.
And I said,
um,
can you tell the chef that Anthony Bordain is here?
That's why I said you dropped that burden to totally ditch cause she didn't,
I don't think she knew.
She,
uh,
so she ran back and the chefs came back with a book and he fucking sign their
book and Shit.
It was the coolest meal ever.
Me and my pal Anthony Giordano and uh,
Anthony and his crazy wife,
his wife wants to fight.
She was like,
could you imagine his wife is a bad ass dude?
She's been doing Jujitsu and Moitai for like four years.
Completely upset.
She doesn't every day one in the morning,
one at night.
I mean,
she's like,
she's got a thick neck and she's got fucking muscular arms and apparently she's
like super,
super aggressive.
I'm like,
wow,
what a,
what a strange situation that would be,
have a wife that might be able to kick your ass.
Man might be able to put a beat.
Nothing you do.
You think you could deal with that now you don't think that you deal with that
now what if you checked,
just started getting into Jujitsu and fucking one of them and then eventually
wanted to roll with you?
Uh,
come on bitch.
Come on.
What if you were fucking her?
And then in the middle she's like,
eat my pussy.
And right when you go down on and she slapped a triangle on you,
it just puts you to sleep.
Could you imagine if that was like fun fire is,
where's your leg?
You tried to get off the bed,
he hooks your leg.
Ohm just slaps that sucker down now he wouldn't be into that.
No.
Would that scare the shit out of you know what if she was laughing at it and
when she said,
listen,
I promise I'll blow every day for
a year.
Cause I was like nothing.
And it's like,
hey,
you want some,
oh sorry.
Shuffle and Nichols.
I shouldn't have taking your soul.
I should.
They choked you unconscious.
Have you always terrified every time you near me now you have to switch the word
blow jobs.
He has to switch it with something else.
Blue top me.
It's an often doing.
Really.
What would she have to do?
Give you money?
No,
I don't know.
Pimp.
We go out in the street for you,
show you so that she really loves you cuddle during a movie.
That's all you want.
Right?
That's why you want back rubs,
you know,
massage.
Fucking Weirdo.
Did you see?
Oh wait,
I think you posted it,
uh,
that,
that Christmas short that was supposed to be in front of uh,
yeah,
they built dying.
His holiday special last night was so freaky.
If you DVR,
no reservations,
DVR and checkout the,
the or,
or,
or find it,
you know,
dvrs or you can search it will probably play in a repeat.
I think the travel network place it all the time because sometimes I like,
I have it set to record all of them,
my DVR and I'll come home and they'd be like 20 of them.
I've been gone for like a week,
like how the fuck is or 20 of these things on here.
But it's just like they play the shit out of their show.
So if you find the holiday one,
it's crazy.
It's so weird.
It's a really,
he told me about,
he told me he's going to be nutty,
but I didn't know what to expect.
I don't want to tell you anything.
No,
no spoilers.
You gotta see it.
It's so bizarre,
but awesome.
Like it was like,
yeah,
you didn't,
it came out of nowhere.
And that,
that this animation that they pulled from the show,
apparently this is like,
did you watch it?
No.
It was creepy.
No,
I can see why they pulled it.
It was a,
it was creepy.
It was,
it was almost maybe,
I think a viral marketing attempt for that travel channel and the whole thing.
Now,
how does that work?
Can we play that on the podcast?
Uh,
yeah.
Are we sure somebody must own that?
No,
no.
I don't know.
I'm sure we can play the Siri thing at the beginning,
but you know it's,
yeah,
but someone doesn't know.
Nah,
that's just a stupid computer voice.
If anything,
the people who won't go the song anymore,
who knows?
You know,
is it,
is it illegal for me to post random movies in the background on the law?
You know,
if it was one inch of it,
don't talk about that.
She knows though.
You know,
talk about that shit.
You gotta bring that up.
It's like [inaudible] don't talk about it.
He'll come.
It's like candy,
man.
I'm not allowed to drive Gary Coleman and my,
no,
you're not.
Yeah.
That's how you know how fucked up that show was.
Two of them are dead.
I love that show.
And that's when they shows.
I grew up in and I love everything about that show.
Yeah,
I need another,
it's so weird watching TV nowadays.
They don't have that anymore because that's not like,
who cares?
Oh,
you're,
you have a little black kid that you adopted so you know,
who cares?
Why is it like a little Air Rakhi kid?
Oh,
you got an Iraqi kid to Iraqi kids and you're an old man could up mash if that
was a fucking calm.
Jesus Christ.
You can't have those kinds of sitcoms anymore.
You know,
you could never have a Sanford and son anymore.
You know?
So
if you have,
if you had anything that was like Sam,
I racist like an all in the family.
Right.
He couldn't have that today.
So how are you going to have,
you know what you'd miss out on 80% of the jokes,
right?
You had some guy with two little Arab kids,
bublé and Abdul.
That's what be the name of the whole thing.
It'd be like the blade with to Iraqi kids.
Stop.
Stop all in the podcast.
I swear to God,
you know,
bringing me in to you retarded world and your boob lay road.
It can be.
So let's talk about this mind book thing,
man.
If these guys wanted us to talk about,
yeah,
when they left,
they have a,
a social networking site they put together,
these are the people that just left,
um,
that were with Mr Lipton and it's called www dot mine book dot dub w s so
there's mine book.
Dot.
Ws.
Why didn't I say www?
What am I a fucking moron?
Like people don't know that just by http colon backslash
backslash thing.
What?
Who Cares?
It's like,
it's forward slows.
That's like,
it's spelled checking me out.
It's weird that,
that it's better.
But that's the same protocol.
Lizzy's little simple numbers.
How long is it going to be before?
It's just say write the word and you know,
and go right to it.
Yeah.
Http dot doc.
I mean if you write cnn.com you don't have to write all that other shit.
Your browser does it for you.
So why do we have to say that?
Why don't we have to know?
I don't know,
but let me,
let me put it in the word and what's ws really stand for website.
Apparently they said it probably something funky country and you know,
probably some weird country like,
like a lot of uh,
like TV was like Transylvania or some shit,
you know,
people,
people uh,
got TV but it wasn't television.
TV stood for an abbreviation of some sort of a country.
Yeah.
People got that at that.
A Internet address,
you know,
you're allowed to.
So I guess you're allowed to get this ws,
whatever it is.
It's probably like some weird country somewhere.
I wonder when it will go bad.
So we don't leave people in fucking in the dark here.
Let me find out what the hell this is the s domain.
But yeah,
mine,
by the way,
I'm going Ballz on
why he's just from watching yourself.
Money for your factor or that too.
Yeah.
That,
that,
that man to wash myself in high definition.
Like,
man,
I'm going bald.
Well.
What's weird is when they showed like,
like at the beginning because they have this my shaggy young hair,
I don't like the new opening.
And is that just temporary?
It's to go
your internist dress.
Okay.
The website dot w s story.
Here it has a ws story but it's weird to see your fucking so much scalp.
What the new,
it's weird on the opening.
They should like the young you and then they showed the old order you and it's
like night and day difference.
How that you've really transformed you look,
you look bigger like media now.
While I didn't lift weights at all,
when I first started doing the show,
I got into really lifting weights probably around like 2001 or two which is
right when fear factor just started because that's when I really got into
Jujitsu.
Right before that I had a problem with my knee.
I had what's called a bucket handle tear and a it was,
it was real bad and it was from years ago and what it would happen was it at
least once every couple of weeks I would be doing something strenuous.
Anything strenuous,
my knee would pop out and lock in place.
So what it is is the meniscus would lift up like a bucket handle and get stuck.
It is fucking horrendous man.
It was a real pain in the ass and it took me a long time before I ever got it
fixed.
And then I finally did get it fixed and then I was able to like really train
hard again because,
but until that I would do something like I would lift weights,
I would bend over to tie my shoe and it would pop out and I would fall to the
ground and my leg would be like locked out in,
in a fund.
And then it was fuck for hours dude.
And then it was sore for weeks,
you know?
And then I would get like a couple of weeks later,
I get to the point where I'll go home and just wear a brace,
go back to class,
boom.
It would pop again.
And the one time I took it really bad,
it popped in tour so bad that I could not bend my leg.
So Eddie had to take me to the hospital and uh,
we went and had to do an Mri on it and they gave me anti-inflammatories and they
eventually they shaved it down and the lady was like,
you know,
you need to stop doing martial arts.
You know,
like they were like really like,
like judgmental about that shit.
The lady like cornered me,
listen,
I'm telling you right now you need to stop doing this stuff.
So I got that fixed and then I started working out like that's when I really got
into like seriously lifting and you're like crazy.
Like,
like on Twitter,
I'd so some people say usually damn Joe,
Roman got fat and so I definitely am fatter.
This is the right.
Will you ever do an episode with no shirt on the whole time?
Well,
people think I'm fatter than I am for sure,
but I'm definitely fatter than I used to be because when I used to fight,
you know,
when I was,
when I first started doing like news radio,
I was in like fighting shape.
I was,
I was in really good shape and I had like a very thin face and my,
my whole body fat was like way lower than it is now.
I can like pinch fat on it and unfortunately that makes me have a big fat face.
It's so funny though,
when every time somebody says that I'm like,
you're well,
I'm not really fat.
I mean,
if you saw me with my shirt off,
you wouldn't say that guy's fat.
No,
wait,
I'm not fat.
Like I,
I'm not thin.
Like I used to be.
I used to be shredded when I was,
when I was constantly doing taekwondo and kickboxing and everything.
I had like five,
6% body fat all the time,
especially when I was going to compete.
And then,
you know,
it never got really heavier than that until I got deep into my thirties when I
was like working all the time and eating shit food,
you know,
like after I did that,
um,
that men's fitness cover,
I was in a cover.
That's why I got those.
That was like the best shape I've ever got in.
And I just got lazy after that.
I didn't really lift weights at all anymore.
I was the today show did,
we didn't,
haven't talked about that you were on the today show.
I didn't even get to see some interesting,
you know,
it was weird.
You know,
they do it outside and this little plaza they do part of it and the plaza,
so Al Roker and I'm,
I'm sorry,
I don't remember the other two people.
I don't remember the name.
I apologize.
It's Jane Pauley.
Is it Jane Paul?
No,
I forgot their names,
but they're very cool people.
Um,
and they're very tall and it looked like a little tiny person out there.
and it's,
so we're out there in the cold and they say,
hey,
fear factors coming back.
Yeah.
Yay.
And it's gone.
It's like it's over and done.
And like,
you know,
Al Roker cracks a joke and that's a wrap.
Did you smoke weed with Al Roker?
Did I wish I did?
I would love to come into my outlook is very friendly.
He's a very nice guy.
He's very friendly.
We see has been every time I met him,
he's a very nice guy.
We is.
Matt lost a shit load of weight too man.
There's a guy who lost a lot of weight.
There's go who recognized that he had like some sort of a problem with his diet
and you know,
live in his life that way and just straighten it out.
Well he did the w the lap band thing.
Right?
Did he do that?
Yeah,
I think that's what he did and I think that he was successful at it.
You know,
we,
we know many people that have had it but they just ate,
started going eating.
I don't know about many,
but we know about one who just keeps breaking those fucking things,
which is so scary.
You know,
the fact that he's just pumping food in there and snapping that cord.
I don't know what a lap,
I don't know how it works.
Do you understand how it works?
I think they just tie off your song stomach,
don't they?
That that can make it smaller and then your stomach does grow.
You know,
if you start eating pack and barbecue into that hole,
that not trying to break it open.
Why did you say barbecue barbecue would be delicious right now?
But anyway,
yeah.
Um,
this guy actually had it done,
which is really funny because all it does is like gets you to not eat as much.
Like you could just do that on your own.
You don't have to get cut open.
But people like,
they,
they trust their will so little that they would rather get cut open,
you know?
Fuck that.
That's craziness.
That's amazing.
It's amazing.
You know,
I mean,
I can understand that when you're like on death's door and you know,
like I got to do something or I,
I'm obviously out of control,
man.
I don't know if that's the thing to do.
I think you should look at yourself somehow,
you know,
whether it's uh,
some sort of a psychedelic experience or you know,
read books and get inspired,
be around positive people,
I think that's probably the better option that's going to make a real change in
your life.
Because having an operation,
even though it's like it pushes you into a certain direction,
like,
okay,
now we're moving positive,
we're getting less food,
we're going to lose some way.
You're going to put less pressure on the heart.
This is all good.
Even though that it's not being done necessarily by you,
it's forcing you to do that.
And whenever you force yourself to do something instead of learning and adapting
your behavior naturally and then having that behavior eventually through
positive reinforcement become the norm,
this is your normal behavior.
Now I actually like to eat greens.
I like to eat a Kale shake in the morning.
I like to be healthy,
you know?
So until that,
until that takes place,
you're just going to repeat the same fucking patterns,
you know?
And that's what our friend who keeps blowing his shit out.
You know,
the issue is not the,
this whole,
you know,
and how to stuff it.
It's why do you want to stuff it all the time?
Like this man,
what the fuck is going on physiologically?
Psychologically I'm,
I mean I'm not against doing whatever the fuck you feel like you need to do to
get yourself healthy.
You know,
you want to do a lap band.
I,
I totally think you should be able to do it,
but I think if I was your friend,
you know,
it's a let's not,
let's not be crazy.
Joey Diaz wouldn't do it.
That's why Julia wouldn't do it.
Joey was like to cut and he,
once they cut you,
they cut you open dog.
Come on.
You telling me that,
that um,
that week I need to do that.
So Julie lost like 80 fucking pounds,
you know?
Did he lose something crazy like that?
He did at one point.
You did too.
You lost a shit load of weight,
Dude.
How,
how heavy did you get at one point?
What's the heaviest you've ever got?
I think it was like,
like two,
four.
I can't spend so loud.
It's like two 45 to 50 or something like that.
Why wasn't it?
And then I got down to,
I know like the lowest I got down.
I think it was like one 69 one 75 somewhere around in your head looked really
big.
Yeah.
Right?
Funny.
I looked weird.
I looked like Carlos Garcia.
It looks well.
No,
he looks better than you left.
I'm going to be honest.
When you,
when you gained weight,
it's a weird thing like your head gets big too.
You know when you like,
even if like you gained weight through like muscle lifting,
you know like guys to like gain a shit load of weight for like power lifting and
stuff.
Right.
It's a not on the sauce.
The fucking heads get bigger man.
Like I have a friend who's really big when you show him this three d that's
pretty dope.
Whoa.
That's a three d that you don't have to wear glasses for.
Holy Shit.
This Nintendo ds is bad ass.
I have a friend who is about 300 320 pounds and his fucking head is enormous.
And I look at his head and I go,
okay,
even if he lost all the weight,
how did his head get this so big?
Did his head grow because it's his body was so fat.
You're like,
what?
What is it that made his head grow too?
You know it does it when you get older.
Your,
your,
your facial facial fucking nose and your ears.
Yeah.
I've noticed that those that might nose seems a larger than it was when I was a
younger man.
I feel,
I feel like it looks,
it looks different from,
it doesn't make any sense,
but it looks different.
Since I had that operation on the inside,
I felt like it got wider or something.
That doesn't make any sense.
Well,
maybe they carved out too much.
They,
they,
they wanted to save something as like a salad.
It's stupid because there was no change to the structure of my nose at all,
but Goddamn,
it works better now.
Anybody was ever thinking about doing that.
I had a,
what's called a,
there's a video of it on youtube.
I forget the,
the technical scientific term of what the,
the operations called,
but they went in and fix a deviated septum and fuck.
That was the one of the best things I ever did.
I couldn't breathe out of my notes since I was like a little kid.
I broke my nose,
fallen down a flight of stairs when I was like five,
my nose was crooked.
So my whole life I've been a mouth breather and fuck,
you know,
and to actually have,
ah,
it's such an amazing thing for,
you said 100% now or do you almost want to go back and get some more co cut out
of them?
No,
no,
no.
It's great.
No,
it's great.
It's wide open.
It's amazing.
I hit the bag with my mouth closed.
I can hit the bag just breathing out of my nose.
I don't do it for like long stretches of time.
I'll take mouth breast too.
But you know,
I want to make sure that I can exert myself.
Like this guy that had been working with,
I've talked about him before,
his name is Steve Maxwell and he's on,
on Twitter.
You find them.
If you go to Steve Maxwell or Maxwell fitness.com or just Google him,
Google,
Steve Maxwell.
I don't,
I'm sorry.
I apologize that I don't remember his name.
He's a the website name.
It might be maximal strength and conditioning.
Either way.
He's a brilliant guy and a brilliant strength and conditioning coach and one of
the things that he has me working on is a breathing.
And so,
uh,
you,
you learn like the correct way to breathe,
to calm your heart down.
Like if it doesn't seem like that would work,
but there really is like a way to calm yourself down.
It's very difficult to do because one of the things that happens when your body
goes into oxygen deprivation,
when you're exhausted,
when you just totally worn out,
you just want to,
Oh,
you just,
you just trying to get Aaron.
Well,
obviously the air that you have right now is enough to sustain you.
You are alive.
I understand that your body is sending messages and saying it needs more air.
We don't have enough air,
but you know what?
You're going to be fun.
You know what's going to fuck you up?
Even worse,
if you freak out about this and your heart starts pounding a million miles an
hour on top of the fact from the adrenaline rush on top of the fact that it's
tired from being pushed and being exhausted and what he's teaching me how to
breathe in through your nose,
like you breathe in like this,
so you're exhausted,
completely exhausted.
You didn't want to just like,
Ooh,
you want to take these big panic breasts,
but that sends panic signals to your body.
You have to control it.
So you gotta be disciplined.
So as you're doing this,
you want to take these breaths,
but y'all,
you do.
It's amazing how quickly it's amazing thing.
Relax.
It's good.
It was a huge lesson to me.
Like now,
like when I'm exhausted working out,
I forced myself into breathing like that and I recover way quicker.
It's amazing.
And all this is like Pranayama breathing.
This is all like in the,
you know,
like ancient yoga guys were like bad ass at this.
Like this is like a big part of yoga was like breath control.
I said,
we're friend,
we should call them yoga ray ray Capone.
He was,
um,
I think that's,
I hope I didn't say his last name wrong.
He would rate Capo.
Thank you.
Correcting myself.
And he was the head of this band.
I forget his band,
but it was like,
I,
I'm a hardcore band,
like crazy wild noise kind of band,
you know?
And they were real popular.
And then he got into yoga and he became,
uh,
this a yoga instructor and eventually it just wound up,
I think he gave up music entirely and he's just like a teaching yoga to people
at some,
some big corporate retreat somewhere in upstate New York who's going to move up
there with his family?
This guy had amazing cardio dude.
I mean,
amazing.
You would never see him cast out ever.
And he told me,
all he did was breathing exercises.
He would do these long,
slow,
deep breaths where you breathe in through your nose and it takes like a minute
and then you hold it and then you slowly let the air out.
Like
slowly.
Like you just want,
your instinct is to just fucking panic and just let it all out and just breathe
in and take gulps of air.
Like you're drowning.
No,
no,
no.
Slowly let it out.
It's very difficult to do.
I've tried to do it.
I do it when I get into the tank is for me the quickest way to get completely
relaxed and centered when I get into the tank.
Pesticides that certain special plant heat.
The other thing is I'm doing these breathing exercises.
You know,
so many people don't know about breathing exercises and don't understand that
you know,
your,
your lungs,
you can condition them and you can,
you can manipulate them and they're,
you know,
you,
you are in control.
You're deciding when to take it breath and you're deciding when to push it out.
And you can use like time honored practices of,
of,
of manipulating that to actually strengthen your lungs and strengthened your,
your,
um,
aerobic capacity.
Because I'll tell you,
man,
this dude just had awesome control of his lungs.
He would never get tired.
That's a Hixon Gracie principle to Hixon.
Gracie was like the greatest Gracie ever,
you know,
pretty widely recognized as one of the greatest,
if not the,
you know,
everyone would say number one,
every Jujitsu guy,
almost a hundred percent would say Hixon Gracie and he's that bad ass.
And the other thing about him is he's a,
he's a Yogi and he,
he has these crazy abdomen muscles math where he's doing these breathing
exercises and the video and he's sucking his whole stomach.
You knew his rib cage and then moving it left and right.
It's like the,
the amount of manipulation that he can do his abdominals and his breathing as
you and I can't even wrap our heads around it.
You watch a video of it,
man,
it's fucking crazy.
Like pull it up on Youtube,
pull up Hixon Gracie breathing,
breathe a breath,
exercises breathing.
Hixon Gracie from the,
from the documentary choke.
And it just makes you realize,
man,
there's um,
there's more to harness in your body than we're aware of.
There's some other shit.
And Yoga is a really interesting aspect of that,
that whole search,
because I found very few things in life that make my head feel as good as yoga
does.
Yoga,
it puts me in like a real relaxed state.
I don't necessarily get to it that often these days,
but um,
when I,
whenever I do it,
I'm always,
I'm always happy I did.
It always makes me feel like a peaceful after it's over.
And I think,
you know,
sometimes when I'm busy with a lot of shit,
I actually subconsciously avoid doing anything enlightening because then it'll
make me not want to work as hard,
not want to get as much shit done,
you know?
And so whenever I'm like avoiding yoga or avoiding even practicing a little bit
of it,
I'm on my own.
I always know that I'm probably working too hard to just find the video.
A hair check this screen right here and tell me if you see,
recognize one.
Hold on a second.
Yeah,
that's it.
Hixon Gracie workout.
Yeah,
he'll do,
he doesn't work out.
And then at the end of it he does like this crazy breathing shit.
Look at.
He's
turn this up,
man.
So much.
He's doing sit ups on the beach right now.
This is the greatest Jujitsu artists ever.
This is the guy where every single family member will tell you Hickson's the
fucking best man.
Yes,
sell and your time to be capable,
to expose yourself in a way to fight and compete.
That's not me.
And it's a beat three or defeat or anything,
but just to be able to,
to do it.
You know
this motherfucker,
this guy is like,
there's not one person that will tell you that he's not good at Jujitsu.
You know what I'm saying?
There's not one person that will not tell you that this guy is a master.
You know,
he comes from a whole family of killers and he's the number one killer and he's
what he's right now doing.
He's is strengthening his neck with his giant Bungee cord.
Really brilliant guy too.
I had a chance to eat dinner with him once and went to his house and discussed
Jujitsu techniques and mixed martial arts,
the physical,
the body as a machine,
as a machine,
we need really take care of,
you know,
so I try be beside a fighter.
I try to keep my physical this smooth as an a combination where they can be very
flexible,
very strong,
very fast,
very well coordinate.
We forgot balance.
We felt good breathing.
So those elements,
yeah,
watch this shit.
This is going to freak you out.
I slow this down.
Stanford.
No,
no.
I'm good.
Sometimes when I make my routines,
I get in a very special stage of meditation and this is beautiful because Lotus
position and totally crazy breathing myself in the present moment.
The it yet,
wait,
wait to hear it goes.
Watch this.
That's so weird.
How he's going to throw your Brad.
You can actually control yourself mentally and physically.
You can really understand your fears and your emotional stress.
You could freak girls out.
I like,
I like the music playing in the background.
Isn't it amazing though?
What did can do with his stomach?
It's very strange to watch.
He's,
um,
he's,
what I would say is a,
a real martial arts master.
You know,
there's only a few of 'em out there in the world that,
you know,
people universally recognized as a martial arts master.
And Hixson is a martial arts master.
He's such an inspirational dude,
that documentary choke.
I guarantee you this thousands of Jujitsu guys all over the world who watched
that documentary choke all the time just to watch Hixon you know,
when Hixon,
you know,
came on the scene,
a lot of people don't know about Hicks and they know about hoist cause hoist
one,
the ultimate fighting championship.
But even hoists said that if he ever got beat,
they were waiting to put in Hickson.
Hickson was like,
plan B.
He was like the atomic bomb.
Like we'll go in there with troops,
but if you bitches,
he kills babies.
Get your shit together.
We're gonna drop Hicks and Gracie on you,
you know,
and he,
um,
he went over and fought in Japan instead.
He fought in Japan valley too.
Dot.
Oh,
there's some politics involved,
some family politics.
I don't,
I don't understand.
All that.
But I do understand that watching him compete was a amazing,
didn't fight enough guys.
You know,
I really wished that we would've,
could've got a chance to see his
high level Jujitsu at work against,
you know,
some of the real best and an a fighters the world.
But when we did see it,
man,
his,
he was so dominant,
man talking to that dude,
you ever talked to somebody and you know,
you just,
you get inspired and you,
and at the same time you're like,
wow,
like this fucking guy is on such another level.
Like with his mind,
you know,
the way he like so serious about things.
Like when you go to the apple store and talking to those guys,
no,
totally different.
Is that how you feel?
I wish I was an apple genius.
I wish I was behind the genius counter anyway.
Uh,
breath control is fucking awesome.
It's like hooking,
try that shit.
It's like cooking,
hooking.
How's it like cooking?
Are you retarded to what's going on?
No.
Like when you're in the jet plane you got,
oh,
calm down tiger.
You silly.
Fuck.
Well you've been saying it's silly shit all day.
I haven't at all.
I've actually,
I,
everything I said makes sense.
Oh,
what's that guy's name that you keep fucking repeating what?
Yeah,
the Sanger.
That's everywhere.
Yeah.
You,
you didn't get silly with that.
No,
I'm telling you I can't stop talking.
Bublé now you're going to see what I'm talking about.
Now that you know who this guy's name is,
it's going to haunt you.
I bet.
Man.
This Nintendo ds thing that you handed me the three Ds thing is amazing.
Yeah,
it's really good.
Like my mom,
she,
the Mario Brothers game,
there was a,
if you're a big fan of [inaudible],
it was so it's done right for the first time.
Being able to do a three d game.
It's amazing.
Like I'm looking at it right now.
It's really a trip because it does,
it even works a little bit or off angle.
Yeah.
But that's the basic,
see,
yeah.
They have to look at a dead on to really get it.
You can see like the wiring,
the board,
there's two things I don't like about it.
One is that it's,
it's,
I have small hands,
but I still found it was really cramped a play at for a large period of time.
So yeah,
I bet it's period of time.
Yeah.
So I got this thing that just snaps into,
it looks like an Xbox controller,
so you can just play it like it's an Xbox controller section,
a button that activate a camera.
It's got a camera,
it's got a three d camera.
You can take photos and three d and,
and uh,
it does,
it actually look like three d if I take a photo of me taking a photo,
yeah,
that would be interesting if you put something in the front in the back,
you know,
like a three like that chair or something.
But uh,
yeah,
it's got a three d camera and uh,
I,
I'm having fun with it.
I think it's,
I didn't know it was that cool,
but that's now way,
imagine when TVs are like that though.
That's us.
You know,
small little screen.
But imagine when TV's,
the three D is going to be this like are these things,
he's mobile game boy type devices or these things sort of like digital cameras
where they're on the way out and it's all going to be incorporated into phone.
The iPhone,
the IPAD,
the IPAD game,
he had iPad itself.
There's all,
this is the coolest thing ever.
I'm still trying to mirroring.
You've done that right mirror and we can do your apple TV and do something even
cooler.
Uh,
there's this new thing called Onlife.
I don't know if you've heard it on live.
It's called online and it's a uh,
video game browser where you can sit here and what it does is it's a service
that you pay for every month and it has all latest video game
so you don't have to have like a high end computer anymore.
You don't have to have an Xbox anymore.
You play through like this weird streaming technology and it doesn't seem like
it would work well.
Meaning like you can sit there,
I can see her right now and played the new Batman video game from my computer in
in real time streams the gain to you.
So you're,
there's no downloading a games,
there's nothing and it actually works fine.
But what the cool thing is is the IPAD has,
I think it's coming to the iPad soon where you can play like legit video games
on your iPad so that you'll be able to play Xbox games on your iPad pretty much.
So
your finger movements will dictate like how,
what is going to be like your controllers and everything.
Right.
And well it's really cool if you can see this.
This is pretty sweet.
What's really cool is that it also,
if you're bored and you're sitting in your bed,
you can sit here and watch anybody that's playing video games right now and you
come and you could just go into their game and just explain to everybody.
Yeah,
Brian just pulled up a browser with how many fucking windows was that?
Uh,
hundreds.
What game was this?
Teen fortress or some shit.
I don't even know what this is.
But they have like Batman,
uh,
they have like any gears drop in on any of these games and just start watching.
So I've been late late.
How you play them?
Can you play?
You can't on on the iPad yet.
That's what I said is just,
is just watching people play.
This is just watching.
This is like watching TV though of people playing any video games,
which by the way,
I used to do all the time.
Yeah.
When I was addicted to quick,
I used to watch a lot of quick demos.
Exactly.
But on android you can play it.
They just released the android version so you can play the games.
Uh,
I downloaded on my Mac and I can play games from my Mac here without having any
video games on,
I think.
And it works really well.
Like I was surprised how well it works.
Wow.
At least for the F for right now.
And five years from now,
that'd be the way to go.
And there's not going to be x boxes anymore.
You're just going to be fucking using your TV and a Bluetooth remote
to your remote controller or whatever you're using.
Wow.
Getting very strange.
But that's called online.
I wonder what the next level is going to be.
It's with this three d thing.
It really makes me think that they're eventually going to get a three d thing
that's going to be your regular television will be three d capable.
Just like everything became HD capable.
You know what I mean?
Hd has been around for a long fucking time,
but how long was it before everybody had an HD set?
Oh,
still the majority don't.
I didn't really want to draw.
I bet the majority still does not have an HD set.
Wow.
That's amazing.
You know I did this tour,
this television satellite television tour where you sit down and they connect to
you with all these different morning shows.
I want to talk to you about fear factor being back and that kind of shit.
And uh,
one of them we have to reset for because one,
one news station somewhere,
one,
one TV station somewhere doesn't have HD.
Right.
So cause because of this one,
they have to reset everything and smashed the signal and,
and do something totally different.
I don't know how they,
they change it,
but they have to change it for this one network and like fucking in the middle
of nowhere that does not have HD.
And I go,
what's that about?
And they'll go,
it's like a mom and pop owned TV.
Why doesn't they,
why don't they just pay for them to upgrade?
I wonder if that's,
it would be more expensive than having to do that.
Super expensive.
You know,
I think it's super expensive.
I mean,
it's a worthwhile investment.
But if you're some rinky dink town and you know,
he got,
I mean,
how many people,
how many people were accessed or how many people have access to each television
set?
Right.
You know,
if it's like,
you know,
Jasper,
Wyoming or some shit,
some weird place no one's ever heard of and they have a TV station and you're,
you're clinking into it.
It's not an HD.
It's crazy.
Sorry to hear that.
The,
that there's television stations that are not HD,
but we have 10 80 p on her iPhone.
That is amazing.
Well,
it's like there's a,
there's a big wave and that not everything is at the front of the way for us.
A lot.
A lot of shit going on the sides.
And at the end it's a,
it's a curious though.
It's curious because if,
if,
if HD,
you know,
eventually it gets replaced by three D,
all of these people that just switched to HD boy like mother Fucker,
I just got the newest shit.
If it ever becomes a,
I'm not a fan of the fucking glasses in the movies,
but if you can show me movies that are as good from like the sides and the edges
as the or from the front and it's three days and we can just watch it on the
screen because right now,
the way that looked,
it's big difference between head on and on the edge,
right.
If you've got to watch like,
you know,
Kona in three d on the edge,
you would get annoyed at yourself.
Right?
It's like it's too fucking clothes.
Yeah.
I,
it's hard for me to even go to a movie theater nowadays that I never go.
I mean,
I have big TVs and digital sounds,
so like even that monkey movie,
I'd never got to see it,
but it's out on DVD,
so I might just go rent it.
I'd been to movies three times in the last month and uh,
two of those three times people were talking during the movie.
I don't want that shit.
I don't need that.
And it was so annoying.
It's like,
you know,
people think it's funny,
they're laughing at Shit,
you know,
they're talking to each other about something totally not related to the movie.
And you hear them laughing.
There's very few things is distracting when when you know you're,
you're hearing someone laughing out loud during a scene in a movie and they know
the problem is there's not a lot of people got into movies these days.
So if you go during a week night,
sometimes you'll go like a 10 o'clock movie and they'd be like,
fucking three couples in there and that's it.
There's no one in there.
Then they're on their way out.
Movie theaters,
bookstores,
you know,
all that shit that day.
IPAD.
That makes me sad.
I'm going to miss both for sure.
I love movie theaters.
I love the idea of like a movie's coming out.
Like when the Avengers comes out,
I want to be there opening weekend,
man.
That's what all the fucking nerves are there.
They're real excited to be there at that movie.
I want to get tickets in advance.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
then it's a fun experience.
You know,
if you see a cool movie in a theater with a bunch of people and they're all into
it,
that actually enhances the experience.
But if you see at theater and it's like half empty and the people we're talking,
God Damn God damn,
that's annoying.
And people,
something that they feel like they can do that when there's less,
less people there.
You know?
That's when I've,
I've found that people are really rude.
It's not when a,
the movie theater is crowded.
It's when there's only like a few couples,
you know,
especially if you get more than three boys together,
more than three teenage boys together.
Like very rarely.
That's all the time for me.
You went three nights,
three teenage boys.
Is that your move?
I don't want put bookstores to go out either,
man.
I love bookstores.
I liked the idea of walking by and going,
Huh?
What is this biography on?
Who?
What did he do?
Oh,
let me leave.
Read about this class life.
I liked that.
I liked that I can just walk down an aisle and go,
you know what?
Maybe I want to read a biography today.
You will.
Or maybe you want to read about cars today.
I want something mindless.
I want to know the history of the corvette.
You know,
maybe it's a,
you know,
I want to,
know about fucking solar power,
but I want to be able to just wander through and pick out something.
It's like the same thing with record stores,
man.
I used to like record stores,
I used to like virgin records.
We'd go and they would let you listen to the CD you remember and there was no,
no fucking headphones available because people would just stand there and listen
to music all day.
And he was like,
damn,
I want to find out this fucking records any good.
That was like the first time anybody ever took a chance.
I said,
listen,
I know that you've been burned in the past,
so here's what we're going to do.
I'm going to let you listen to everything before you buy it.
I remember that was like fucking revolutionary.
Yeah.
Now people download the whole fucking thing and if they really like it,
they'll buy it on iTunes.
I still bought you.
Most people don't do that,
I don't think.
I think most people would just steal nowadays,
but I still buy a CD here and there.
Definitely.
Yeah,
but the problem is I don't go to a record store.
I go to Amazon and I just get them delivered to where it was.
I just add,
oh,
I was at best buy and there was like so many things and I'm like,
that's cool.
I'm going to wait.
Let me just go on Amazon.
Oh Shit.
Yeah,
it's 40% cheaper on Amazon.
Is it really 40% so many things.
Here's,
here's a good example.
I here,
this is kind of obvious.
So,
uh,
urban outfitters has this uh,
video game system that it plays like old Nintendo,
old Super Nintendo,
old genesis.
Anyways,
they have it for sale on sale for $100.
It's on Amazon for $44.
Holy Shit.
And then that's just like how best buy is.
You know,
like best buy is all the time.
You just go through everything and you're like,
wow,
on sale [inaudible] windows laptops are like 700 bucks.
How much can you get a good windows laptop?
You can get a good windows laptop or 300 bucks,
Holy Shit.
And that you're not going to eat editing video.
But nowadays,
Shit so cheap.
That's amazing.
You can get a laptop for 300 bucks.
Like a good one.
Like a Toshiba or something like that.
Absolutely.
That's amazing.
That's one of my favorite complaints too when people start talking about apple.
Well,
you can get the swims books in a windows box for one third the price,
but yeah,
but you'd be running windows.
Do you understand that?
That's silly.
Goose people get mad at me.
Man.
That's one of the things I've had uh,
mentioned on Twitter.
People will say something like,
dude,
I think you're cool and everything until you start talking about Mac and PC and
you don't know what the fuck you're talking about.
Like whoa
and want to change to Walmart's or touchy computers.
Someone got a little touchy
son was a little uncomfortable with the of the fact that
your shit gets viruses will do,
can make rooms for the mirror platform as well.
It's just not enough people doing it for them to judge for a making it.
Yeah,
whatever.
Okay.
I think those people would be so that the people that write viruses are probably
on windows and they would probably want to destroy the apple fan boys as much as
possible.
If they get it.
They're trying to extract money is what they're trying to do.
If it was easy to extract my,
there's just a big enough market with windows computers,
why fuck with it?
It's so easy to get into your shit.
You know I have to do is click a link.
I mean how stupid is that?
You Click a link and you get a virus.
Hi.
Oh,
sorry,
you're a fucking virus detection wasn't ready for this.
Oh,
I just snuck into your basis and I got your pregnant.
Sorry.
Stupid and all your data's no good.
You know,
hell spawns inside of your making babies.
I tell you what's the most annoying thing in the road?
Somebody told me to call this number.
It was like 1-800-WET-TITS.
As,
as on one of the other podcasts.
He's like,
Oh,
you know my,
I got a new one,
800 number and they settled.
He wanted everyone to call this number and what it was,
it's like winning a hundred wet hits or boobs or something like that.
And it's just his girl going,
Oh,
you want money?
I have really web boobs a,
it's like a recording.
And then at the end of like this two minute speech,
she,
she goes,
uh,
she's like,
call this number.
You know,
dad,
talk to me live.
But the problem is now ever since,
because I called her on my phone and be on speaker phone just so we could play
on the podcast problem.
Is that now nonstop.
Everyday I'm getting a text message like automated like hey,
me and my crazy roommate want to suck your butthole out in call this number,
you know,
and it's like I'm now in a spam on your phone.
Do you get spam on your phone ever?
Um,
no.
I don't get on once.
He never get like random text messages that are like trying to sell you or do
something great.
I don't know what to do now.
I am sure I can call a t and t but and tell him I got your number because I
called a phone number and I got automatically put on some text message calling
list.
She could block them.
I'm sure you'd find out what number that's coming from until eight t and t no
text messages from them.
But that should be a good industry against the law because I mean I call it
accidentally called that number by mistake.
Now that you,
you're just signed up for some spamming.
That's,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
It's true.
It's bullshit.
Yeah.
But whatever,
it's amazing that it's taken this long for them to infiltrate,
you know,
thinking about how long people have been getting text messages and just now
they're figuring out how to get in there.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
You know that,
that's pretty incredible when you really think about it.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Dude.
Now with the Patriot Act,
they can listen to everything.
They can listen to all your calls with every fucking new bill that gets passed.
They can dig into all your text messages.
It all in the name of you could be a terrorist.
All you have to do is be like a single guy in your forties you could be a
terrorist.
You know?
All you have to do is,
this is like such,
all you have to do is have like a year's worth of food.
It was like someone was,
I forget who did a,
a,
a description of it,
but,
uh,
was it John Stewart?
I forgot who it was,
but they had this,
all these descriptions of what,
what is defined,
how it defines a terrorist now it's unbelievable.
It's ridiculous.
Like if you have missing fingers,
you,
you could,
you should,
you could be a terrorist
if wear that.
I see a watch that I have.
You're a terrorist.
Yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
That one watch.
Yeah,
that one watch because they use that for timing shit.
Right,
right.
It's just standard standardized just to watch a fucking regular watch.
Right.
And then you could be on a watch list.
God dammit.
How did this all fall apart?
Like this?
Yup.
Bruce Lipton got kind of freaked me out.
Yeah.
Do any freak you out a little?
No.
I mean,
I think for the most part it was really good.
It was really,
uh,
you know,
I either believe that or don't,
and I,
I've always kind of believed what he talks about,
so I agree.
I don't know.
It's,
I 100% believe what he says.
You know,
who's going to freak you out,
man.
Michael Rupert and I get that guy on here who's got to smoke cigarettes with you
to remember smoked cigarette every five seconds.
That collapsed movie man.
I know.
Right.
You know and I want you to talk to him too about the whole thing to be said
about the cell phones.
Remember he said they were there,
stopped upgrading their towers and you're like,
oh yeah,
he's probably changed his mind now cause that's just obvious now that know.
But,
but that does speak to a direction,
right?
That he was going in.
Yeah.
I need her when,
when is I want to read,
watch that movie again.
Oh No.
Cause I remember I was really lost out on a few things on that.
But we're,
I'm exchanging emails back and forth with his assistant,
so we're working that shit out.
So many people I want to get on the podcast.
Yeah,
me too.
Like who,
who else?
I want to get nick [inaudible].
Nick Swardson back.
Yeah.
We'd love to get nick back if he's got more than 45 minutes to kill Kevin
prayer,
Kevin would be great again.
I told you I did talk to the show yesterday.
You saw it.
He's great.
I went to his Christmas party.
It was awesome.
Oh yeah,
I saw pictures of it.
What the fuck was he dressed like that,
that he had a p nine Dx,
a holiday party.
And so you were supposed to dress a holiday sweaters and mixed with P90x
clothing.
So the x,
the workout program workout program.
So the P90x cause I have no idea Andy Xmas.
This is what it was.
Yeah.
And so you had to come there with your favorite uh,
ornaments and stuff like that.
So I cut off the Avatar fleshlight a vagina and put a hook in it.
Oh No.
Yeah,
I watched it and a hook in it.
Yeah.
And hung it on the tree when I walked in a no.
And then,
uh,
it was,
it was cool though,
be his,
his,
uh,
he was one of those arcade games I thought was pretty about this.
He hasn't mame arcade game.
We,
which had like every single,
allegedly every single video game on it.
And like he had dragon's layer space.
He's like,
and there was this game called Raskin.
I don't know if you remember this from the,
I think it was the 80s.
It was like this Conan O'brien guy and he,
it was just like a simple slasher like it Conan O'Brien's slasher.
And it was one of the coolest games to see,
cause I haven't seen it since I was a kid.
It's a checkout Rasta and see if it brings back memories.
It's like Conan O'brien.
Dude.
I was on watch it and the barbarian,
they were showing some game.
I don't know what it was,
but I believe it was a game for the IPAD,
some crazy fantasy game.
You're upgrading your weapons and swards some,
but it was like really wild fucking animation.
And I was watching,
I was like,
this is incredible.
It's on an IPAD.
It's really new.
You know who's that?
It was the room viewing it.
Yeah,
it was a cliff.
He's game
one of his,
uh,
the
dude.
It's fucking amazing looking.
I mean it's,
it's incredible.
And I'm,
I was watching,
I was like,
wow,
we're at the level where that is coming out on a fucking iPad.
That's incredible.
Yeah.
The iPads pretty bad at us and supposedly the third one's going to be the room
or at the latest rumors.
There was February 3rd one's gonna Rub your Dick.
It seems like they just came out with a second one.
I'm kind of getting angry about that shit.
Well,
it's been almost a year.
I think they're doing one a year.
I still have the first generation.
I'm an old holdout.
I'm like one of those dudes you meet that has the,
the iPhone with the aluminum and the bottom guys don't use those anymore things
without a would,
you can't use it anymore.
I mean you have to like,
you barely use them.
They,
you can't,
you have to have to not ever up to your iTunes.
Yeah,
yeah.
A few up to your iTunes or you're fucked.
Everybody says that to what you were saying,
that when you,
whenever you update your operating system on the older phones,
it just like,
it seems so clunky.
Yeah.
They get a kick
ass for the,
for the new shit,
for the next level.
Shit.
Yeah.
But they do it on computers.
They're forcing you,
they're holding your hand.
You can look at it and that they're forcing you in a bad way.
But actually the forcing you to kiss the fuck up.
It's a positive in general.
Everyone's faster getting shit done faster.
Yeah.
Guess playing with yourself faster.
Right.
Did,
uh,
did you see that shootout that happened here on,
yes.
What the fuck was that?
I don't know.
But what's crazy is I,
I found,
uh,
they released his name.
I read this small report where they released the stores.
Okay.
So there was this guy on,
I think it was right next to the movie theater that has settled down,
I think of Hollywood and vine that just had a gun and he was walking down the
street and just every time somebody would drive by just Bam,
Bam shooting people like nonstop.
One guy got hit in the head who was a music executive here,
and I think he might've died,
uh,
hit him in the head of just,
he just pointed him right in his head and just Bam,
I,
and so he was just walking down,
so you're doing all this shit.
Finally the police came and they shot him down and they killed him.
Um,
but what's crazy,
they released his name finally.
It was like a 26 year old.
And if you go to his Twitter page,
uh,
I tweeted it,
I don't know where it is,
it's on my timeline,
but if you go to his Twitter page,
uh,
he,
like was that his photos are the people we followed.
We're all marijuana activist,
gun activists and then span shit.
Oh.
And then so I found this Facebook then went on his Facebook and his Facebook.
He,
he brought his like six days ago,
uh,
broke up when she was single and relationships.
And he was like saying things to,
you know,
like I finally get what Steve Jobs last words or something like that.
And then I'm like,
oh,
great.
But what's weird,
it's like if you looked at what he,
a watch,
like his interests on Facebook and stuff was like cspan and like weird shit.
Like who?
Who wants a cspan one and two?
That's what it says and yeah,
that's like,
that's like looking at your registry,
right?
Yeah.
And he also was like,
uh,
his Yoni tweeted like three times and one of his tweets was like,
ah,
Charlie Sheen need more tiger blood.
I ran out like,
Whoa,
Jesus Christ.
There's some sad crazy fuckers out there man.
Right.
That's a scary thing.
Know that this guy would just randomly start shooting people.
That scares me to see that the video that,
that they have are fine.
It was very scary.
It was terrifying.
It just walking down the street shooting at cars,
innocent people.
Yeah.
It's scary shit man.
But you know,
you have to worry about that whenever you have,
you know,
more than more than 10 people,
even when you have 10 people,
man,
you know,
how many people do you ever known someone when they were young,
they were normal.
And then as I got older they got crazier and crazier when reality didn't sort of
fit their,
their vision of what reality was supposed to be.
And then they started doing a lot of creepy shit and you know,
never really sort of saw the world for the way it really is and then they start
getting crazy.
Yeah.
Have you ever met people like that a lot?
Most comics,
a lot of them.
We know a lot of them that were crazy.
Right.
Yeah.
That's an interesting thing to say.
It's an interesting thing to see someone legitimately lose their grip on
reality.
Yeah,
we've seen it.
You and I have seen it.
We've seen it many times.
Yeah.
It's fucking weird,
Huh?
It's weird.
Weird watching people slip away.
So what do you do about that?
I can't do shit.
Nope.
Can't bring them back.
They've got to bring back themselves.
I just totally forgot what we were talking about right before this last thing.
Todd bridges and the olive garden.
You need to take him to the off guard when that that would,
that would be nice if you guys,
I don't want to hang out with them.
I just,
I feel bad that I said that I shouldn't have.
You know,
it's not in keeping with my idea of a being a positive person,
but that's just a,
sometimes shit happens when you get tired and you say something you shouldn't
have said.
That's why you know,
no one's perfect.
We apologize and then we move on.
[inaudible]
from where to get to your man.
Todd bridges is a nice guy,
I'm sure.
And he's,
he gets it.
He probably,
well I just don't like when I do something like that and I don't,
I don't like how I was thinking,
you know,
sometimes you get tired man.
Fuck it.
Make some fucking mistakes.
You know,
if you get tired and cranky or if you're a,
you just overwhelmed,
overrun or overburdened.
Do you find yourself like when when you're tired and cranky,
like you just don't like your behavior?
Lately I've just been a complete asshole just because I have no time.
I feel like certain times with your girl,
like sometimes she like it deteriorates your relationship because you're tired
and you're just snappy,
you know you're not,
it's to me it's to me it's like I'm in my own road cause I'm trying to deal with
a thousand things that are coming at me and,
and so like the other day I had to check myself and I had to like say,
all right,
look,
I am completely ignoring my relationship right now.
I'm like,
I need to stop or stop working as much.
So I made my,
I'm making myself not do as much on purpose.
Like I'm taking a day off here and there where like I went almost two months
like every day to the Yellow Band,
Huh?
Yeah.
I didn't need to activate long band controlling the situation.
Um,
well that's,
that's something like it need to work on like,
because I have not even talked to him about anything.
Like the other day I was on stage and I got off stage and they were,
they turned off the podcast are nice house chronical and I'm like,
what?
And they're like,
well,
we wouldn't go to open,
so did turn it off.
I'm like,
wait,
you're the guy in charge.
Don't you know why you knew I was coming back?
But you know,
it's just working out that now.
He will never do that now.
I'm like,
no,
don't ever do a little bit of trial and error.
But that's like what's cool about the Joe Rogan experience.
Like we started off with snowflakes and everyday and allow something new.
Yeah.
On a laptop just for a goof.
And now we're coming up on two year anniversary,
so we're going to have to,
um,
we're going to have a celebration of this shit.
Yeah.
We were also,
this week we're having two shows and Saturday we're having a huge party.
So maybe that could be the celebration that's going to be our,
yeah,
that's close enough to the,
uh,
the time we started on like New Year's Eve,
right?
Wasn't it Christmas Eve?
Christmas Eve,
Christmas Eve.
So yeah,
we're right there.
I mean,
what is it like the 13th or something like that today?
Yeah.
Have you ever heard of the Rose Bowl parade?
No,
I haven't,
but I've heard of it.
It's right here.
This is,
what does that happen?
I think,
I think New Year's Eve or New Year's day or something like that,
or Christmas Eve or Christmas Day,
they podcasts from the Rose Bowl parade.
They put these things,
weird signs on the street outside the studio here.
And they say,
uh,
um,
any cars parked here from December 23rd to January 4th are subject to
inspection.
Oh,
well then that makes sense.
I know you can't have someone Parker fucking dirty bomb.
Yeah.
But does that mean any kind of inspection?
And they just want to look at what kind of cds?
I want to say to his homeland security.
They're gonna find your weed to fund your weed and your girlfriend's porn.
They're gonna lock you up in jail.
I gotta take the anonymous mask out of the window for it.
Take the fucking anonymous mask out right now and put a fucking American flag.
How about that?
Oh,
you have these,
um,
these,
these things you have in front of the windows.
You know,
we hang American flags.
Yeah.
We needed more American than our our thoughts and ideals.
It was real America,
not this bullshit.
Actually corporate swindle fast.
It's going on,
Brian.
Real America is about speaking your fucking mind.
It's about creating something,
uniting together in one giant bond as the greatest nation the world has ever
known.
So we should put up our fucking flag because we truly represent America,
not those cons that we try to stop us.
I might hang mine upside down.
Oh,
you're crazy.
You're too crazy.
That bad.
Is that most of it?
Yeah.
I wouldn't do it if anything that would piss off a soldier,
whether whatever it is for people hanging upside down and look at them flack
from my rack and he's had a fucking hard time and he's loading up his gun.
Right.
When he drives by your window and sees you in an upside down flag decides to
pump nine into your fucking window.
Huh?
What if you have somebody hanging upside down and then it's upside down upside
right for them.
Oh,
okay.
I see what you're saying.
So you have the world is upside down.
I think you can get away with that as long as you have like little bushes and
stuff by the guy's feet as well.
No,
the theme
has to be clear,
the guys to be glued to the ground,
like he's a walking,
walking through the park and the American flag,
it was just,
they're all nice and proud.
Just upside down from your perspective.
Right.
But he lives in Australia.
It's called thinking up,
you know,
get them to the land down under where everything's upside down.
You know what Australia,
you can't even fuck around outside.
You got to put sunscreen on because their ozone layers gone.
Oh that's so weird.
They've got a big hole in the ozone layer.
So when you're in,
um,
did I say Alaska?
I don't know.
No,
I think you said,
I'll start to tell you I'm in Australia if I just say Alaska because it was
going to say something about Alaska as well.
But in Australia they have like these ads on the side of buses and they're
fucking pretty graphic man.
And they show people with chunks of their body cut out from skin cancer and they
show the stitches and it says,
you know,
it's,
I forget the ad campaign,
but the basic messages,
hey,
you can get this from the sun dude.
You gotta be careful.
And then interesting.
That's weird.
Yeah.
They have a,
they have more issues than we do.
Apparently that wasn't layers of motherfucker and everybody says it was
hairspray and all sorts of different things that eroded it boomerangs
terrifying.
We were,
you imagine was,
well I guess it just all settles down there by the way.
The,
uh,
the earth is built.
I don't know if that's,
that's a theory that's been disproven or proven or what,
I finally watched tangled and I really liked that movie movie man.
My little,
my,
uh,
my middle,
middle one told me yesterday that she's not a,
she's not a fan of tangled anymore.
Why not?
She has this tangled fan and,
or this tangled thing and her,
her room,
she's like,
I don't like tangle anymore.
It's funny thing about kids,
they love something and then they watched the fuck out of it.
It was Dora the explorer for a little while.
She would watch the fuck out the door.
They explore and now she doesn't want to have anything to do with it.
They move on to the next show and then it becomes the next show that they're
massively obsessed with.
You know,
it's really interesting but tangled down.
But just a year ago,
man tangled,
you know when we took her to see it and then she saw did though in the movie and
then we got a DVD and brought it home.
Oh my goodness.
She couldn't watch it enough man.
You know what's the craziest thing?
Because every time I launch a venture and venture time,
I have to watch the kids commercials that kids commercials for toys or the most
tripped out insane.
Like if I was,
if you're a coke addict,
never watched kids cartoons during the day and look at the commercials.
There was one about these.
Th th the toy was little crabs that had makeup on and like really nice
hairstyles and it was just the commercial made no sense.
Like why would they be marketing to kids like dressing up crabs.
It was intense.
That sounds ridiculous.
I tweeted something,
um,
earlier today I retweeted something that someone's sent me where they were
talking about kids today and all the different people.
Um,
I'm going to click on it just so everybody knows what it is.
R s a animate,
changing education paradigms and paradigm is spelled p a.
S if you,
you're a target like myself,
that was rude.
I apologize.
Um,
but this is a very interesting little thing that someone made a,
that points out how kids today are inundated with so much fucking massive,
massive amounts of information and that,
you know,
to take these kids and force them into watching something really boring all day,
like school,
like staring at a blackboard and then,
you know,
you wonder why they're incredibly,
detached from what's happening there.
Their world is the world of explosions and fucking video games and intense music
on there
on their iPhone.
It's,
you know,
there's loud and emotional and you make them shut that off when you come into
this room to tell them boring shit.
You know,
I mean it's almost like what we know and he was talking about earlier about
programming.
I don't think it's like a conscious effort to do that.
I think it's just they're lazy and it's just the shit design.
But man to take kids and take them from the world that they can experience now
with the Internet and video games and movies and songs and cars and and and
technology and then make them sit in the fucking class and listen to stupid shit
all day.
It's amazing what they need to do.
They totally need to do this electronic arts and teach Q and all these big video
game companies need to start selling video games that have to do with shit day
and what the teach the people.
If I,
if you ask me any question on fallout three or whatever like like about bottle
caps or whatever.
I know exactly what you're talking about.
I've memorized,
I have this thing memorized in my head.
I will never forget it.
I know the manager,
if they should do,
if you could teach kids through a video game that would actually let them like
go back on an adventure through time and they learn about history and like be a
part of it.
Yeah.
You're George Washington,
you,
you'll know everything about George Washington by the end of that video game.
And the kids will remember that.
Every single kid likes to play videos.
Yeah.
But you would go back there and just start pumping people go grand theft auto
style and started fucking shooting people off their horse and you make it.
So if you do any of that stuff you,
you,
you get taken away recess or you get a detention.
If you fucking shoot somebody in the kneecap,
you get detention.
You know,
I guess I can start at the beginning of the end though.
I Dunno.
History.
Interesting.
You know,
you'd have to have some really entertaining person,
like who is like a history major or a history professor rather.
It was just really good at figuring out the best way to,
to construct the stories,
you know,
and getting,
getting you into it and then showing you cool shit too.
That's another one like showing you documentaries and cool pictures and stuff
like,
but you know when you get to certain things like mathematics and stuff like
that,
how are you going to make a video game where kids learn math and they and that
it's fun.
It's fun for someone who wants to play like fallout or they'll do something like
call of duty,
you know you want to play call of duty and then maybe let's play numbers.
Right.
You know,
I wonder,
I don't think you can teach that
unless it was something like a Sim city or some kind of like,
you know you,
you're married to the octomom and it's like a math video game thing.
I guess so.
Well some people love math.
I'm just talking shit cause some people actually sit down and do mathematics for
fun.
I hate math so much.
We had tear Patrick and the studio the other day and her biggest turn on is a
guy that knows math can really,
you know why?
Because she wants him to know exactly how many dicks she suck.
She wants him to really be able to wrap that around his head.
She was just not to be vague.
Oh honey.
I know you stock a couple of things.
Listen,
I'm telling you bullshit.
Listen to me.
Do you know what a million is?
He?
Can you wrap your head around a million?
She was Prager's man,
she's starting to nice.
She's got that little,
you know Prager juice on her chunk on her.
What?
She's got a little,
you know like that.
She's got a little chunk tour.
You beat off to pregnant checks.
You sick.
Fuck I did because it's a different,
do you know?
I don't look for it,
but I'll be like,
damn,
that girl was pregnant and hot.
Double billing.
Oh really?
That's amazing.
So when you were around her and she was hot,
it was like exciting.
It.
She,
she just,
she,
you know,
there's a few girls,
like she's,
she's just hot to be around.
You know,
there's a few guards with its,
you know,
smell like scold the girl school,
you know.
But you know,
she would,
she's gorgeous and she just,
she,
you know,
she retired so she hasn't shot in like four or five years or something like
that.
She,
she's a born again virgin.
Basically.
She just released a new,
a photo shoot on some foreign magazine and she brought it and it was nice.
She has a nice body.
She's pretty odd and a nice husband or boyfriend or father of the baby that's
coming.
What's he do?
A,
he's a makeup artists.
Oh.
But he just did like the new superman movie and stuff like that and said like,
he's a legit,
like,
he was really cool.
He's a really nice guy.
It's just a funny
think we're,
some dudes just can't accept that.
You know,
some dudes are never going to be able to accept the fact that check was a porn
star.
Yeah.
You know,
and some guys just like,
yeah,
whatever,
whatever.
I'm getting mine.
Yeah.
I Dunno.
It's interesting how weird we are with sex.
It's a strange culture where everything is sold with Saks,
but yet if you,
you know,
she really get down to the nitty gritty.
We're really fucking weird about it.
We're really insecure about it and insincere about it.
It's strange,
right?
We have a fucked up culture man.
It is a weird culture.
You actually try to suppress nature.
It's a strange,
strange fucking way we live man,
but selling things with pussy,
you know when that makes sense.
When you get married,
when you get married,
it makes sense because when you're single and you could,
you know,
you know like,
well if this relationship doesn't work and we break up,
I'll find someone else and that'll be interesting because it'll be a new person.
But when you're married and your commit to this idea that you're just going to
be with this person for the rest of your life,
then you start like seeing some chicks selling watches.
Ooh,
that dirty bitch,
that dirty bitch with a fucking long legs.
Like it really like attracts you.
Like,
maybe this Omega Watch is going to get me some of that,
you know,
it really does work.
You know,
it's,
it's funny,
it's like I guarantee you if you had a commercials for like a cell phone service
in Ethiopia and you showed like delicious food in the background,
you know,
like here's a cell phone,
it's fucking roast beef.
They're mashed potatoes and giant pictures of orange juice,
all this yummy food and these poor Fox would probably look at that like,
oh,
and they would want to buy that cell phone.
Doesn't that make sense?
Yeah.
It's,
podcasts is over,
isn't it?
Pretty much.
Yeah,
sure.
We've done I think over three.
Yeah.
Well we had to come back cause I had to give my apology to Todd bridges.
I really do feel Bob felt I felt stupid about that.
And uh,
we really wanted to talk about fear factor because it was pretty fucking crazy.
Awesome.
I can't wait for it.
This,
it was very rainy Monday,
right?
Yeah.
Every Monday for a while we only did eight of them,
so it'll,
it'll air quick.
But the ratings were giant.
There were monster.
Everybody's super,
super happy and you're going to,
next thing you know,
you're going to be picked up and knows like for another season and you're gonna
be like,
Oh dude,
we start filming again in two weeks.
It could be,
and it's going to save you from the Japanese radiation.
I'm going to have to shave my head.
I can't keep looking at my balding head on TV.
It's just too sad.
I have to do something about this.
Oh,
well we're wigs.
That'd be funny.
Oh,
you wear a different wig?
Every red wig.
Red Wig,
like Bozo the clown.
That's what I'm gonna get.
I'm gonna get a red wig,
but it only on the sides.
Only like around the ears,
ear muffs.
Um,
this weekend we have,
oh,
if you want to come to that Chicago show,
it's almost sold out.
Folks.
Uh,
Chicago 20 January 27th,
2012 Joe Diaz and Duncan Trussell at the Chicago theater.
It's going to be off the fucking chain and that is the same weekend that Fox two
is scheduled.
So a,
that card is a great car.
Does Rashad Evans versus Phil Davis?
Um,
there's a,
there's a bunch of great fights on the undercard of that as well.
Michael Bisping versus Damien Maia.
That's a great fucking fight.
So it should be sick.
It's a great card for Chicago and um,
it's gonna be awesome to be on Fox again.
And then the night before that we have a show at the Chicago theater and it's
the same place where the weigh ins are,
which is pretty bad ass.
Yeah.
So we're going to basically do the way and get something to eat and then,
and I'm rocked the house,
but Dunkin and Joey together is,
this is a,
a rare one.
This is going to be fucking fun.
Uh,
thank you to the fleshlight and please go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link for the flashlight and entering the code name Rogan.
They had been our sponsor for a long time now.
It's been like shit,
like a year and a half or something like that.
Cool company with a very cool people.
That's how we met Aubrey.
Go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link and you get 15% off.
And like I said,
you're buying something from some good people or don't buy it,
man.
I don't care if beat off on your own.
That's all good too.
I'm a great court Christmas ornaments.
Just chop off the very tip of it.
I can't believe you butchered it like that.
It's Mrs Clause.
I caught it frozen.
Mrs. Loss
from outer space.
Oh thank you.
Also to on at.com.
Makers of new mood.
These two I use on a regular basis,
new mood and Alpha brain.
And whenever I work out I use shroom tech.
Uh,
new,
uh,
new mood is a five HTP a supplement and it also has,
um,
a field trip to fan which converts to it.
So it's,
it's a nice,
got a little time release effect and it really is like a nice mood stabilizer.
I don't want to say stabilizer.
It's an enhancer.
Makes you feel good.
Neil Brennan is want to turn us onto it.
Um,
uh,
I,
I appreciate it.
I like it.
Alpha brain as well,
which is a cognitive enhancing supplement that I,
I swear by it.
Some people don't like it,
some people love it.
It's all on you.
If you don't want it,
don't,
don't buy it.
If you do buy it and you don't like it,
hundred percent money back guarantee,
which is nice.
So even if you,
you know,
you don't have to send it back in and you eat it,
you say this shit sucks.
You get your money back if you're interested in it,
but you think it's too expensive,
please go to the website,
find the ingredient list and then buy this stuff in bulk and make your own shit.
And I'm more than welcoming.
I'm not trying to get rich off this,
but these are good products that I personally believe in.
[inaudible] and it's on a.com oh and and it,
and if you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for Alpha brain and the
entering the code ne Rogan,
you will get 10% off food and you get smarter.
What?
Flashlight really dropped the ball on that?
They should definitely have mrs clause fleshlight what the fuck happened?
Like be like creepy to be the best Christmas toy ever to give us a joke.
Yeah.
With white frosting around it,
like really wrinkled,
looking like,
like to super low.
Maybe it's not too late.
They have full factory dude.
First slide.
Feel free to use Brian's idea.
Brian,
you want any money for that now?
Just sponsored the death squad podcast sponsor that's from class.
Oh,
by the way,
if you want to listen to the icehouse chronicles,
we've been doing podcasts,
podcasts,
he,
that's like a podcast for cows.
We've been doing podcasts for the last four or five weeks doing this.
Um,
and we do them from live,
from the ice house,
and they're called the ice house chronicles.
And is my opinion,
one of the coolest podcast we do because you know,
it's not,
it might not be as structured as today's was,
which is today's,
you know,
this is a different kind of podcast.
Today's with Bruce Lipton was brilliant and he was,
it was amazing.
It was eyeopening.
It was like really,
really made you think about things and I really enjoyed it.
But um,
with the,
the d,
The icehouse chronicles,
it's really a hang.
It's all of us,
all of us comics.
It's a green room.
It's a real green room for real,
legit.
It's uncensored.
It's everybody's sitting around and sometimes it needs to be censored,
but to Walsh fiasco.
Oh yeah,
I know I need to do about that.
I need to do,
need to delete that and get that off line.
Um,
but it's,
um,
it's,
it's a,
it's a really fun podcast and the only way to get it is if you go to iTunes and
subscribe to the death squad.
Death Squad is a,
the podcast network that Brian Producers and it contains not just,
uh,
the icehouse chronicles,
but Sam Tripoli's Naughty Show,
Thomas Hager and Christina girl,
even though she uses some other fucking name that's called your mom's house and
they have a great,
uh,
John Heffron.
We just had a lip.
The guy from,
uh,
what type maybe you show me the money.
Jerry Maguire Maguire and he,
he's been training Jujitsu and martial arts since he choked the fuck out of
jail.
I'm halfway done.
We had him on the show.
He was so awesome.
Very interesting guy.
That's great man.
That's great.
That's good to hear.
It's,
he's a child star that actually survived.
That's why is that what it is?
But we're also,
he'd stopped being famous for awhile and kind of like leveled out normal.
No good for him.
A thank you to everybody for tuning in.
Thank you to everybody who watched fear factor.
My glad you enjoyed it and thank you.
If you don't,
I don't give a fuck.
Folks,
we're just here to have a good time just yourself and please,
if you get a chance,
if you're only listening to this podcast,
listened to the David Lipton one that we just did,
cause it's really a fucking an interesting take on how your thoughts control
your reality.
All right pitches.
We love you.
We will see you if you're a Hollywood person,
New Year's Melrose.
Impove Brian is going to be there to Brian Immune to create some kind of a video
for this shit show at a Hollywood improv new years.
I think it's Joe Diaz,
me and I don't know who the fuck else,
but it'll be crazy.
Whoever it is,
it's going to be good.
So uh,
we'll see you freaks soon.
Sometime this week.
Who am I doing this week?
I've got some,
I'll Duncan Duncan Duncan tomorrow.
Alright.
Haulage boy.